c'est là qu'habite souvent joué et merci
d'être heures en direct avec nous alors
tout d'abord qui sont ces gens qui
rendent hommage à une division ss
aujourd'hui en ukraine
eh bien vous avez du vide à une
résurgence du sentiment ou en tout cas
de de l'idéologie néo-nazie il ya ce
travail qui était fait les qualités
permis par mes permis aucune par les
pays occidentaux
parce que du courant en relançant cette
idéologie nazie
eh bien on fait du russe un ennemi une
assimilation aux soviétiques de l'époque
et quoi de mieux pour les attentistes
aujourd'hui pour washington que d'avoir
une un foyer de tension sur la frontière
russe que d'exciter les ukrainiens dans
un sentiment antirusse et donc du coup
de rappeler ce passé sombre histoire
l'ukrainien ou pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale le lombric unien se sont
battus du côté des nazis pour pour leur
idéologie et contre contre une autre
partie de l'ukraine qui était pas de cet
événement de 7 à 10 de cet avis là mais
qui aujourd'hui à plus voix au chapitre
mais les nazis sont un phénomène répandu
aujourd'hui en ukraine
très répandue très très répandue et nous
le savons depuis depuis longtemps joe
biden qui a été six fois pendant son
mandat de vice président des états unis
est allé de nombreuses fois en ukraine
des américains des français des
allemands savent très bien avec qui a
pris le poids en 2014 sont les
atlantistes qui les ont permis qui les
ont soutenus nous voyons aujourd'hui des
personnes comme à andré parrot by qui
était du québec et président de la rada
qui est un ancien fondateur du mouvement
social national ukrainien qui est devenu
par la suite soldats nous avons
différentes personnes différents acteurs
de cette révolution de l'oru maidan qui
ont été très actif en 2014
qui sont les qui ne cachent pas leur
sympathie le soin pour le troisième
reich ce soit pour les idées et
extrémistes qui sont connus d occident
où les occidentaux aujourd'hui qui sont
au pouvoir et dont les idées se
dissimule dans la société aujourd'hui et
malheureusement ce genre de parra n'est
pas du tout surprenant et écouter le
silence les capitales européennes jambes
lisses d'ailleurs de lui beaucoup de
condamnation de ces défilés non
j'aimerais ajouter une chose qui est
importante en 2020 l'union les nations
unies ont voté une loi pour condamner la
glorification à du néonazisme
aujourd'hui on demande la majorité puis
des nations unies vont voter à cette
résolution l'union européenne s'est
abstenu deux pays ont voté contre les
états unis et l'ukraine
je pense que tout est dit et justement
dans telle mesure est ce qu'aujourd'hui
kiev pour lutter contre ce phénomène
ils ne peuvent pas ils sont complaisants
ça veut pas dire que toute la société
ukrainienne et les nazis et violent il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui résistent
mais le pouvoir a besoin de jeunes gens
galvanisés excité parce que du coup ils
ont cette mission de la part des états
unis qui tiennent un peu l'ukraine et
les attentistes qui tiennent l'ukraine
financièrement de maintenir un foyer de
tensions avec la russie c'est la mission
de l'ukraine pauvre les attentistes
aujourd'hui tu
malheureusement la vérité de dire que
les attentistes en rien à faire du
soutien économique à l'ukraine ils
veulent se servir de l'ukraine pour
comme un foyer de tension pour la russie
et donc du coup aujourd'hui le pouvoir
en place et les américains ferme les
yeux sur ces mouvements néo-nazis qui se
répandent parce que beaucoup de ces
jeunes gens vont aller se battre vont
aller se battre au donbass et donc du
coup si vous voulez galvanisé exciter
les gens bien vous avez besoin d'une
idéologie qui va quelque part leur
donner une raison le vit dans une
société où l'économie étape là où il n'y
a pas beaucoup d'espoir à part fuir le
pays et donc du coup on ferme les yeux
en s cette idéologie se répandre et
cette idéologie se répandent de plus en
plus ya plusieurs rues en ukraine
aujourd'hui qui portent les noms de
stepan bandera qui est un collaborateur
notoire delà de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
vous avez ce genre de défi des key qui
se déroule aux avaient le sang sans son
sourcil en l'ukraine sap a été condamné
par les autorités légales donc du coup
le pouvoir a besoin de ces jeunes
excités parce que leur mission et voilà
est de faire se feront d'eux d'avoir ce
foyer de tension sur la frontière russe
pour embêter moscou dernière question
très rapidement à la rando la de ce
phénomène
aujourd'hui l'ukraine est imprégnée d'un
sentiment nationaliste au fort très très
fort très fort parce que c'est la seule
chose qui va tenir le créneau et
l'ukraine mine de rien une construction
récente avant la première guerre
mondiale il n'y a pas de pays qui
s'appelle ukraine et pour fait et
c'était un pays qui se délite
on a une toute une partie qui
s'identifient comme russophone qui était
très heureuse
d'être de se dire de vivre en ukraine
mais qui aujourd'hui se voit opprimés
par un poil elle est là là là
les médias d'opposition où se tient
aujourd'hui trois médias récemment ont
été interdits personne en parle à
l'ouest c'est la réalité et donc du
coupé ya une division de la société je
parle même pas des hongrois de
transcarpathie pour essayer de souder la
société bien une espèce de sentiment
ultra nationalistes c'est une erreur
parce qu'elle qu'une partie des
ukrainiens qui se retrouvent dans ce
sentiment ultranationalistes et le
pouvoir en place
pense qu en galvanisant qu'en
interdisant les minorités avoir accès à
leur langue qu en galvanisant le
sentiment ultra national quitte à
rappeler ou à fricoter avec des
mouvements extrémistes comme on voit
dans les images actuellement et bien
qu'ils vont pouvoir unifier le pays
c'est une erreur c'est une erreur de la
part de la part du pouvoir ukrainien
parce que du coup ça va se retourner
contre aujourd'hui parce que ça ne fait
que de distiller la haine entre les
populations locales et entre les
populations européennes
merci beaucoup en tout cas nicolas
mirkovic d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes analyste
politique